soir terre car tenez donc vous êtes
porte-parole d'une association qui
s'appelle cabiria et vous faisiez partie
donc de cette grosse manif devant le
sénat mardi dernier faut rappeler quand
même que c'est la première fois que les
prostituées manifestent en france depuis
1975 on va pas faire un débat de trois
heures j'ai simplement posé le problème
clairement
on al'impression je vous dis franchement
l'impression quand on regarde ce que
vous faites avec sarkozy que vous
traiter le problème de la prostitution
uniquement comme une nuisance pour les
voisins c'est à dire que le problème en
fait pour vous c'est l'air d'être je dis
pas que c'est pas un problème d'ailleurs
mais ça a l'air d'être des prostituées
qui pratiquent leur art dans les cours
d'immeubles les préservatifs sur
lesquels on peut glisser le matin en
sortant de chez soi je dis pas que c'est
pas un problème je dis qu'on a
l'impression que c'est comme ça que vous
le voyez en tous les cas alors ça règle
pas le problème de la prostitution en
général parce que si elles sont pas sur
le trottoir et si elles sont pas dans
des maisons closes puisque les maisons
closes ont été fermées en france par
marc trichard en 1945 où vous voulez les
m nous sommes confrontés aujourd'hui à
des dangers importants
j'en ai parlé la prostitution étrangères
oui le trafic de drogue vous savez très
bien que les proxénètes moi je connais
plusieurs problèmes les progrès
proxénètes les proxénètes qui exploite
les réseaux de prostitution étrangères
bien souvent ne sont même pas cela votre
projet de loi y a pas un texte contre
les proxénètes
vous attaquer aux plus faibles les
prostituées étrangères que vous renvoyer
dans leur pays et les prostituées
françaises que vous mettez en prison
nous nous donnons les moyens en les
interpellant
de leur proposer soit d'être raccompagné
à la frontière et de se voir retirer
leur titre de séjour soit de se voir
donner un titre de séjour de longue
durée un porteur de moment où elle nous
donnerait l'origine de leur filière et
le nom de l'an est essentielle la
première fois on sait qu'on donnerait un
droit quelqu'un qui dénonce des ratios
cela se regarde on donne un besoin
contre délation il s'agit de détruire
des réseaux de proxénètes
les françaises maintenant elles n'ont
pas le droit d'être contre toi l ont pas
droit d'être dans des maisons closes
puisqu'en france n a plus qu est ce que
vous en faites est ce que vous pensez
sérieusement que sarkozy et vous vous
allez éradiquer la prostitution dans ce
pays ça existe 2 d'emi léger a coûté
j'avais le sentiment de vous avoir dit à
plusieurs reprises que tel n'était pas
notre intention
nous savons bien que c'est le plus vieux
métier du monde nous n'avons pas la
volonté de le remettre en cause fait
partie de l'histoire du monde rien alors
est ce que répondait nous est ce que
votre idée derrière tout ça ça serait
ouvrir des maisons commis en allemagne
il ya des 0 5 2 en allemagne mais non
mais entre entre le racolage et la
pratique d'une prostitution qui ne passe
pas par la voie du racolage il ya un
chemin d'accord donc j'adore la
prostitution sur internet mais c'est pas
sérieux
au racolage est à moi de le définir mais
ça y est simplement mais simplement
c'est la droite catholique ils vont tout
nous variés simplement je vais l'écrire
je peux vous affirmer aujourd'hui que la
plupart des gens modestes soutiennent
ces dispositions il vous suffit de lire
les enquêtes d'opinion tous les jours
75% d'opinions favorables au texte
sarkozy j'imagine que dans ces 75 % il
n'y a pas que des électeurs de droite et
lorsque je vous dis que 80% des gens qui
touchent le smic aujourd'hui soutiennent
ces dispositions c'est parce qu'ils en
ont marre c'est parce qu'ils en ont
assez d'être humilié de devoir baisser
la tête lorsqu'ils rentrent dans leur
hall d'immeuble le soir pourquoi pouvoir
arpenter un trottoir sans être agressé
ne pas pouvoir laisser aller leurs
enfants classe tous les matins sans se
demander si ça ne sera pas ce jour
qu'ils se feront racketter proposé de la
drogue voire agresser sexuellement dans
les toilettes du lycée ou du collège
c'est ça la réalité
nous ne devons pas individualiser la
prostitution d'un côté l'exploitation de
la mendicité de l'autre les gens du
voyage de l'autre il faut regarder les
choses de manière transversale pour
pouvoir enfin créer une échelle de peine
et des sanctions graduées juste aproprié
sans excès sans outrance mais qui
globalement ramène la paix civile dans
notre pays c'est ça l'esprit du texte de
nicolas sarkozy vous savez ce qu'il ya
dans le projet donne monsieur sarkozy
des peines pour ceux qui travaillent qui
ne traverse pas la route sur les
passages piétons et lorsque le bonhomme
est vert non et quand il ya trois
personnes en bas d'un immeuble alors
quand on va chercher son courrier en bas
et qu'on se retrouve avec deux potes en
train de discuter on est susceptible de
finir 7 24 heures au commissariat et si
les abeilles sont en mini jupe
plus en plus comme on les fait en tout
cas en france nous sommes très
minoritaire chez vous mon cher thierry
saussez s'était installé au nom ses
pattes alors à travers les territoires
de sécurité moi j'habite dans une
banlieue où il ya des tas de gens qui
gagnent le smic je vous rappelle que et
c'est même une banlieue au au deuxième
tour il ya le mec de l'ump avait pas pu
rester donc les mecs du titre qui gagne
le smic ne votent pas tous pour l'ump et
deuxièmement moi mes enfants ils vont à
l'école et moi ce que j'ai peur et j'ai
bien eu raison c'est que lorsque le toit
le tout alors que leur leur tombe sur la
tête parce que la seule fois où il est
arrivé un accident c'était parce que
l'école n'était pas entretenu parce que
parce que parce que nos normes parce que
l'air parce que la sécurité c'est pas
ses pattes c'est pas vos fantasmes à
bout parce que vous avez une permanence
dans une banlieue où vous allez [ __ ]
vous allez poser vos fesses un quart
d'heure par semaine les listes énerve
pas les cheveux juste exclure les exclu
qu'on a tué ceux ci les élus ni la
position difficile aussi il est tout
seul là il arrive dans un
désintéressement que miner magog à toi
tu attends deux secondes finalement j'ai
fini ma fille et j'ai fini il a
effectivement une situation où quoi qui
va dire quoi qu'il va faire évidemment
qu'il faut le critiquer le juger mais il
ya un lever de boucliers tout de suite
parce que on va sortir passante en
attentant je finis le juste le principe
il ya une levée de boucliers au temps à
venir soit 4% de la france d'en bas
rhône où les votes pour nous c'est
dangereux valeur tout celui qui l'a
laissée dangereux à pied mais c'est
dangereux aussi de 2000 cherchons c'est
aussi dangereux de dire que mais
attendez mais où est ce que tu as vu un
racketteur alors qu'il ya du racket
c'est dangereux aussi de dire les
banlieues s'est fait pas ça je vis dans
les bouquins chez moi dans ma classe
quand même salle qui a déjà pas draguer
milliards
mais y'en a battu peut pas décemment
dire quand il dit que j'étais des gens
n'avaient pas d'en exiger
sept-îles et prennent de sécurité de
l'école c'est les problèmes de machin
c'est décidé en face on a des nazis et
du coup le français que milieu quand il
faisait coup tous les deux ils pensent
quoi il pense que là il est le type qui
parce qu'il habite dans la banlieue et
qu'ils ont la vision de leurs banlieues
et 10 la banlieue c'est ça vous venez
pas loin d'en parler et de l'autre côté
lensois on ne peut pas attaquer
estime pas non c'est pas ça dure mais
c'est pas ça du tout c'est que le prem
c'est qu'il ya dans la place à son move
it que je trouve pas ça normal c'est que
tout d'un coup mais qu'est ce qu'on fait
qu'est-ce que vous qui trouvez pas ça
normal il fallut je suis pas dans son
camp en train de tourner je trouve sur
ce registre on devrait diriger la
politique vers l'éducation et nouvelle
formation des gens et nous un nouvel
avenir que plutôt que par la répression
et je veux bien qu'il ait peu de mots en
bestiaux qui sont difficiles qu'il faut
critiquer et où on a raison de les
critiquer de dire attention sarkozy faut
pas qu'il aille trop loin ils essaient
pas que parce qu' il arrivait qu'il a
quatre points devant auxerre lille face
quelle meilleure mais c'est pas la peine
non plus de dire attention les problèmes
vous fantasmez vos problèmes vous 30 à
semer la banlieue ou fantasmés c'est pas
vrai non plus il faut trouver les
réelles solutions au problème de fond
c'est ça qu'on parle mais pas mais n'en
vendra la série j'allais si on réduit la
solution le débat de moi je te dis mais
de les joueurs ont bien raison la
sélection sont situés ou parce qu'ils
traînent en bas d'un immeuble c'est pas
une solution c'est tous ces plans
sociaux mais alors le ski d'isola
seulement mais c'est ce que je dirai que
c'est pas une solution c'est trop c'est
au bout d'un an ça mais je suis pas si
je suis en moi je fais de la musique ou
les débats quand il dit j'espère que
c'est assez réussi de l'extérieur la
black edition qui sont trop hauts que tu
ne sais pas alors vous vous offrez
impossible de vous entendre impossible
de discuter impossible d'avancer une
omerta la côte équilibre on va finir
chez hitler et l'autre qui dit bon
j'espère que ça allait passer mais tout
ce qu'on franchement ces débats pour le
français qui écoutait ce débat il n'y a
pas une information qui est passé mais
sérieusement
dix ans que la répression est uniquement
la répression ça ne peut pas être une
solution c'était pour qu'on dit et ce
qui se passe ça peut pas être qu'un tir
de barrage avec ce mot là bon ça veut
dire la répression n'ont pas
l'impression tout d'un coup tout de même
la répression et les lois ne sont pas
blessés en textes et lois sont que des
répressions donc on s'insurge contre eux
ça ça va ou pas dès qu'on voit un type
qui arrive qui dit ce qui est d'autant
plus odieuse et un type a bien peu en
caillera façon et qu'à une casquette de
travers à ce moment là on appelle ça un
délinquant et oui mais voilà aujourd'hui
un problème qui va dire il faut faire un
peu de réflexion parce qu'on déverse est
un fasciste c'est pareille date la
mécanique de visualiser depuis des
plaques ya quelque chose sur quelqu'un
elle est dans les deux sens si c'est ce
qu'on dit dans nos textes on généralise
comme ils généralisent c'est eux qui ont
le pouvoir c'est eux qu'on la façon de
penser excuse moi non subie toi on voit
les excuses mais on subit tous les jours
je suis pas que sa patience oublie pas d
excuse moi bien je vais vous laisser ce
que je voulais c'est le coût de la
charge et j'ai un peu compter les points
attendez avant de vous laisser répondre
que si ça vous dérange pas qu'on discute
votre loi qu'on parle à la télévision
non ça vous embête pas non parce que
c'est ça le dialogue la déprime acier
que nous recherchons d'ailleurs
madame bâ ici madame faisait allusion au
maire de lyon oui je vous signale que
les ps le maire de lyon et membre du
parti socialiste je pourrais faire
référence à georges frêche le maire de
montpellier qui les socialistes à jean
marie bockel le maire de mulhouse qui
sont socialistes aussi est qui et qui
aujourd'hui parce que ce sont des hommes
de terrain et et qui mesure les
difficultés au quotidien dans leur ville
soutiennent aujourd'hui ouvertement ce
texte bon ça démontre bien que c'est pas
simplement un débat interne à la droite
aujourd'hui c'est une volonté finalement
plus partagés qu'on imagine d'apporter
de vraies réponses aux vraies
préoccupations et aux vraies priorités
des français et pour vous répondre et
pour vos réponses solution les gens
disent irène motorisés je voudrais je
voudrais vous répondre parce que vous
avez beaucoup parlé répression la
répression n'a aucun sens ce qui a un
sens c'est une politique globale si vous
n'avez sio n'est pas tout les politiques
vous avez par l'éducation vous avez
raison à ce que vous savez que 80% des
délinquants mineurs ne savent ni lire ni
écrire c'est un vrai enjeu
c'est un vrai des parties de mettre les
messages à l'ena et c'est tous les mêmes
mais sûrement et ben voulez vous je vous
dis je je partage totalement votre
position d'accord et luc ferry s'est
engagé à faire pour priorité à s'engager
prioritairement vers cette lutte contre
l'illettrisme c'est de manière
transversale en abordant tous les
problèmes pour répondre à chaque
difficulté que rencontre notre société
depuis trop longtemps que nous
résoudrons toutes ces difficultés et le
texte de nicolas sarkozy apporte
simplement encore une fois sans excès
mais très courageusement de vraies
réalités vous savez madame nous sommes
très ouverts vous m'avez parlé de
l'accueil que vous avez reçus au sénat
je peux vous promettre qu en tant que
rapporteur de la loi sur la sécurité
intérieure pendant les cinq semaines qui
viennent avant la présentation de mon
rapport devant l'assemblée nationale
jeudi ciel très près de 35 associations
depuis la ligue des droits de l'homme
jusqu'au bras en passant même par l'abbé
pierre par un certain nombre de vos
représentante et je vais vous le dire ce
soir je serai heureux de vous recevoir
devant la commission des lois de
l'assemblée nationale au même titre que
des syndicats de policiers des syndicats
de magistrats ou des syndicats d'avocats
parce que notre devoir est d'entendre
tout le monde est de trouver la voie la
plus juste pour apporter la réponse la
plus équilibrée de toute façon ils vont
nous recevoir mais les écouterons
toujours pas merci d'être venus
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un peu
de bleu